raiga carries everything that's just the
universality of reggae music scene so
easy star is taking the universality of
reggae and taking it to places it's
never been before with the dub side the
radio drill and neither sergeant helpers
project and that is an honor in and of
itself so you glad to be part
we're gonna take a trip to the Dark Side
of the Moon
you know a sense of a demo and they
listen to it they're like so we sit the
fact that they could easily turned it
down and say no we're gonna let you do
it with the fact that they did they must
have seen you know something in it
don't be afraid again
so just to get that respect to know
original artists to get their cool
because they liked what they heard in
the demo that that's enough to just say
yeah you know even if the fans didn't
like it we can say well they fluoride
like they are you know Radiohead like
but you know which they did their food
up okay we'll see how you know Sir Paul
in our gringo responds it is
the people that run the label are really
believed in the roots the beginning of
reggae and they they really want to
share that with the world and that's why
they kind of chosen the records that
they've chosen some of that a huge
audience
music that's something that we all
really strongly believe and we got to
give props to Michael G he's really the
mastermind I do sir the man who knows
the reggae and made all the arrangements
on these records so Michael direct
checking for Wired magazine the scene